manchmal fragt man sich echt wohl lebe
ich eigentlich gibt es keine anderen
probleme im fernsehen existieren
mittlerweile jede menge shows in denen
es um die suche nach der großen liebe
geht mal mehr mal weniger erfolgreich
nun soll das zum ersten mal im weltraum
stadt wird moment wie bitte und das ist
gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich denn elon
musk ist mit einem ass im ärmel mit
dabei
pixum science fiction jeden tag
spannende fakten aus dem bereich
weltraum und wissenschaft abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's aktive
kommen heute mit tim von astor comics tv
die suche nach der großen liebe ist für
viele menschen ein wichtiges thema und
das kann man ja auch gut verstehen das
ist ja auch eine wichtige sache doch
keiner würde dafür so weit gehen wie der
japanische milliardär kazuo kimura denn
der würde dafür sogar zum mond und
zurück fliegen er hat im japanischen tv
eine dating show namens full moon lagers
geplantes konzept ist bekannt aus
mehreren frauen sucht er seine traumfrau
aus nur dass die folgen nicht auf der
erde spielen sondern in einem raumschiff
das zum mond und wieder zurück fliegt
total irre bei zara sagte dazu gefühle
der einsamkeit und der lehre haben mich
beschlichen und deswegen suche ich nun
meine traumfrau mit der ich aus dem
weltraum liebe und weltfrieden verkünden
kann
wir dürfen also gespannt sein ob wir
bald die erste suche nach der großen
liebe im weltraum beobachten können kein
geringerer als der milliardär ihnen mast
hatte auch seine finger im spiel
denn meist aber hat das liebes
raumschiff sozusagen weil der firma von
elenas spacex in auftrag gegeben und die
haben auch zugesichert bis 2023 das
raumschiff zu bauen man darf also echt
sehr gespannt sein
ein bisschen bizarr wäre das ganze schon
denn das wäre der erste bemannte
raumflug zum mond seit den
apollo-missionen wenn man damals jemand
gesagt hätte er das nächste mal wenn wir
zum mond fliegen wird das im rahmen
einer trash tv show seien hätten
wahrscheinlich nur alle seltsam geguckt
ich finde das ganze ein bisschen
fragwürdig denn welches frauenbild wird
hier transportiert stadt mädchen und
frauen dazu zu ermutigen astronautinnen
zu werden oder wissenschaftlerin
werden sie als teilnehmerin dieser
castingshow im weltraum zum bloßen
beiwerk reduziert dabei gibt es ja
gerade in den berufen der astrophysik
also astronautinnen wissenschaftlerin
noch viel zu wenig frauen also man
sollte sie eigentlich eher dazu
ermutigen mitzumachen stadt casting
teilnehmerin zu werden und ob das ganze
überhaupt klappen wird steht auch im
wahrsten sinne des wortes in den sternen
denn spacex ist nicht gerade dafür
bekannt fristen einzuhalten alleine an
der dragon kapsel die das erste mal
wieder astronauten und materialien zur
iss bringen soll hat das unternehmen
sechs jahre gebaut
es wäre natürlich ein großer coup space
jetzt gelingt eine modifizierte dragon
kapsel als liebes raumschiff für die
show einzusetzen mal sehen danke dem
space extrakte explodiert beim staat
ihnen musk ist begeistert warum erklärt
tim auf seinem kanal asto comics tv
anklicken anschauen und auf jeden fall
abonnieren und tim dabei helfen die
20.000 abonnenten marke zu knacken
hammer typ hummer kanal bis dann bleibt
dran